in potsdam begrüße ich die fdp
bundestags abgeordnete linda teuteberg
guten abend
gute namen dich grüße sie
gestern ist ein entwurf für einen
gruppenantrag aus den reihen der fdp
fraktion bekannt geworden der sich gegen
eine impfpflicht ausspricht und sie
gehören zu den unterstützerinnen warum
sind sie gegen eine impfpflicht
es handelt sich um einen antrag gegen
eine allgemeine impfpflicht ich werbe
für das impfen es ist die beste
möglichkeit für die meisten erwachsenen
menschen sich gegen einen schweren kopf
19 verlauf zu schützen ich halte
allerdings eine allgemeine impfpflicht
für das falsche instrument um das
wichtige ziel dass sich möglichst viele
menschen möglichst rasch freiwillig
impfen lassen zu erreichen sowohl im
angst als auch wut darüber sind keine
guten ratgeber wir müssen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass alle die sich impfen lassen
wollen schnell geimpft werden aber warum
ist ihnen damit dann die freiheit einer
teilweise aggressive minderheit
wichtiger als die freiheit einer
mehrheit der bevölkerung die ja für
impfungen ist
die gegenüberstellung funktioniert ja so
nicht zum einen die impfung ist und das
will ich ganz klar stellen sie ist
wichtig und gut weil sie vor schweren
verläufen schützt und das ist auch schon
wertvoll sie gibt uns allerdings keinen
absoluten schutz vor
infektionen deshalb wird sie übrigens
auch nicht zu vollständiger freiheit wie
das jetzt gegenüber gestellt wird führen
sie ist aber notwendig damit wir schwere
verläufe vermeiden und nicht das
gesundheitssystem überlastet wird und
wir deshalb wieder mehr
mehr gesellschaftliches leben
ermöglichen können das ist richtig aber
wir müssen auch fragen was sind die
folgen einer impfpflicht und wie soll
sie praktisch funktionieren da sind ganz
viele fragen offen zum beispiel wie oft
müsste denn geimpft werden wir haben
gerade gelernt auch durch omikron dass
da nicht alles so ist wie es vor ein
paar monaten noch galt das heißt es geht
darum möglichst jetzt überhaupt den
impfstoff an die menschen zu bringen das
ist ja gerade für januar leider schon
zweifelhaft wir müssen aufklären und
werben und vor allem erstmal auch all
die die sich jetzt impfen lassen wollen
impfen
auch boostern diejenigen die schon die
ersten zweitimpfung haben und nicht über
pflichten diskutieren die sogar eher
noch die spaltung und trotzreaktion
verstärken könnten na gut die spaltung
ist ja im prinzip schon da und je mehr
ungeimpfte es gibt desto stärker steigen
die zahlen und desto eher werden die
freiheiten aller beschnitten also
diktiert dann eben doch eine minderheit
der mehrheit wie es geht
also zum einen ist nicht ist nicht
bestritten worden von mir das ist ein
problem ist wenn wir viele ungeimpfte
haben deshalb müssen wir die impfung
forciert und dafür werben es ist
allerdings auch so dass wenn man eine
pflicht regel der muss man wissen was
sollen die sanktionen seien und es ist
eben keineswegs so trivial anders als
etwa bei den masern womit ein oder zwei
impfdosen ein lebenslanger schutz da ist
lernen wir doch gerade weil der profit
impfung dass sich immer wieder die
erkenntnisse ändern wie lange sie
wirksam ist und wie soll denn dann die
pflicht auch geregelt werden soll das
dann immer im herbst gelten oder alle
drei monate das sind praktische fragen
und es kommt auch die frage hinzu dass
führende politiker vieler parteien das
ausgeschlossen haben eine impfpflicht
das hat sehr wohl einen politischen
schaden für die debatte in deutschland
und ich will dass wir mit voller
überzeugung für die impfung werben und
nicht den eindruck erwecken wir müssten
sie erzwingen weil sie irgendwie
problematisch sei sondern genau ganz
dezidiert dafür werben dass sie für die
allermeisten menschen der beste schutz
ist aber es hat ja bisher noch nicht
vollständig geklappt karl lauterbach hat
heute vor einer fünften welle gewarnt
wie glauben sie denn könnten wir diese
herausforderung ohne impfpflicht
begegnen
indem wir zum einen ganz praktisch dass
impfen forcieren und wir stehen doch im
moment vor der realen situationen dass
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister
gerade festgestellt hat dass im januar
der impfstoff knapp werden könnte und
zwar für diejenigen die sich gerade
impfen lassen wollen wir können jetzt
nicht über vor den praktischen
schwierigkeiten die augen verschließen
wir müssen natürlich alle impfen die
sich impfen lassen wollen und noch mehr
menschen überzeugen die das bisher noch
nicht wollen dass sie sich möglichst
auch impfen lassen wir müssen mit 3g und
2g konzepten sinnvoll infektionsschutz
organisieren in den verschiedenen
bereichen
aber wir werden mit einer bloßen
diskussion über eine pflicht und auch
nicht mit einer pflicht die wir dann am
ende gar nicht durchzusetzen bereit sind
denn die frage ist wie soll sie
durchgesetzt werden ernsthaft mit
unmittelbaren staatlichem zwang
bußgelder sind ganz bestimmt keine
sinnvolle lösung wenn es uns wirklich um
die sache geht und deshalb sind da viele
fragen offen für mich spricht mehr gegen
eine allgemeine impfpflicht und sehr
viel mehr dafür dass wir jetzt die
priorität auf das praktische leben
nämlich endlich genug impfstoff für alle
die sich impfen lassen wollen und noch
bessere aufklärung bei allen die wir
noch nicht erreicht haben bei der
finalen abstimmung soll die
fraktionszugehörigkeit ja keine rolle
spielen
das gewissen ihr parteichef lindner hat
schon angekündigt im bundestag
voraussichtlich für eine impfpflicht
zustimmen wie einig ist sich die fdp den
derzeit bei diesem thema
nun sie haben gerade gesagt es wurde
freigegeben wie dort abgestimmt wird und
jeder abgeordnete jeder abgeordnete muss
hier selbst abwägen wie sie und er es
sieht und ich komme aus verschiedensten
gründen sowohl aus
verfassungsrechtlichen bedenken der
verhältnismäßigkeit denn für jüngere
menschen zum beispiel die kein die
weniger von einem schweren verlauf
bedroht sind stellt sich schon die
verhältnismäßigkeit frage aus
praktischen erwägungen der umsetzbarkeit
einer impfpflicht wie oft soll das
stattfinden und auch aus fragen der
politischen klugheit was bedeutet das
für unser gesellschaftliches klima dazu
eine allgemeine impfpflicht abzulehnen
und es ist eine ganz wichtige sache im
demokratischen prozess dass alle
meinungen auch abgebildet werden und
dass deshalb mit einem solchen
gruppenantrag auch die chance besteht
für diejenigen mitglieder des
bundestages die eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ablehnen dass sie auch
dieses verhalten diese meinung zum
ausdruck bringen können dazu dient die
vielfalt der anträge und wir tragen
einen antrag dazu bei linda teuteberg
vielen dank für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen wieder